good morning everyone welcome back to
gamespot live i'm richie and today we
are going to be playing
some call of duty it is spooky season
so
there's a lot to do here and i honestly
don't even know where where to begin so
i'm going to switch over to multiplayer
there's a lot going on multiplayer modes
pumpkins everywhere so i'm just going to
get started i'm already late so
apologies and
welcome let me say what's up to the chat
make sure everything's going
firing we had some technical
difficulties with audio which is
just the best it's the best thing in the
morning you know
but enough dawdling let's go multiplayer
where should we begin there's uh
there are a lot of modes here
yes sir what's up we got people over on
the gamespot youtube page hello and
gamespot trailers channel what's up you
guys here we go the haunting
so
yeah and there's a new sm
sorry there's a new smg that you can
unlock by doing all this stuff i don't
even know where to begin
scream death match let's just do it i
think this is the one where there are
ghost face killers to like two of them
and everyone else has no weapons you
just have to hide so
i think let's do that first
and then we got to play some we'll see
what's going on in warzone
we'll see what's going on um
we got to do some prop hunt look at the
background ooh
also let me know you guys uh we had
audio issues this morning before i
started so
i want to make sure the game audio is
okay um
and and you know
jiving with my voice not competing with
it so let me know please
oh standoff for sure okay
i'm going to
scooch up
looking good i have a spooky light back
there it's red oh
let me mute everybody here
hello hey chat
let's see the store okay after this this
match
um i'll look at the store because there
are there's new stuff and i definitely
want the donnie darko bunny
um
uh bundle for sure
friend of show jeez that's clear
warzone zombies i played
there are ghosts in zombie uh there are
ghosts in the warzone mode
uh but so we'll get to that too look at
this i have no weapon
and there are just ghost face killers
with armed with knives so wish me luck
scream deathmatch oh that's funny you
guys know
escape the killer
i can only i can only punch hey look
yay
don't kill me i have candy i'll give you
i saw one
you guys know that uh the voice of ghost
face killer in the first movie was steve
bloom aka spike's beagle himself aka he
does every voice in the world and he's
awesome
oh my god
don't punch me i'm on your side
there's gotta be a there's a fear meter
or something look at that
i'm screaming like every 10 seconds oh
look in 10 seconds on the left there i
think i'm gonna just scream like it's
prop hunt
oh no
i should hide and not run around like a
doofus
i didn't scream
still alive still alive
i wonder if the ghost face killers are
faster
oh
he's around here somewhere
oh [ __ ] i'm out of here nope oh right
now i'm one of them do we have to kill
each other or just kill the survivors
hey oh man okay well that's dumb
okay i didn't turn into a ghostface
killer i just was armed a knife
and i blew it so now i know what to do
yeah look at that embarrassing replay
it's show time great
oh now okay great
i've got one
go around here
oh sorry man that's a cool captain's
outfit though
oh i've been stunned
i like how the mask show is just like
the
screen mask
like the shadow effect is fun
okay how many do we have it looks like
um
two out of five
oh yeah it's like prop on where they
scream
it's downstairs i think
i'm gonna whip you up
nice right here
rambo
[Laughter]
damn it i can't fight can't win a fight
against rambo
oh right
we win
oh this guy must have got two in a row
or something
oh right in the shoe
flavio is donny coming out it's not it's
not actually donnie darko it's just the
uh i forget his name in the movie but
it's the guy in the it's a bunny costume
bundle
i wonder if i'll be a killer this time
come on
nope
where should i hide
can't jump this nope
or should i be hiding should i be
running hiding
oh the new screen bundle is 20 bucks
yeah that's pretty
that's high but it's normal
unfortunately i don't think i'll pick
that one up
[Music]
oh i saw one over there i'm out of here
oh oh oh
oh
no
get away from me
i thought i could juke him nah he got me
with the tomahawk
yeah that was really bad
[Laughter]
infamous i'm really sorry to hear that's
terrible i hope you're i hope you're
healing well
i've always had a thing for you
ben yeah that's his name in uh and
donnie darko the bunny costume guy ben
i've seen this one before
white mask knife fleeing victim
i've seen
well see look we can we don't even have
to buy the bundle we can just play this
game mode and be the ghost face killer
himself
switch over here looks like we have
oh there she is
no yes
gone
great this mode is okay it's it's not
bad i like my favorite parts just
actually seeing the ghost face killer
and hearing hearing him say things just
like in the movie uh but there's plenty
more to do so maybe after this match
i'll look around i wanted to check the
store for for you guys in chat to see
what's new
and uh oh wait this this match is still
going okay
how does it work
playing with revolver ocelot oh really
all right the classic slasher story i'm
a very good player no i'm not i don't
know was that a gamer pro
no way bro
just having a little fun
but that's very nice of you oh no okay
i'm not a killer again so i gotta run
for my life i'm gonna stay over here
i had good luck in this area
oh no someone died right outside i'm
getting out of here
maybe over here this is a pretty good
spot
oh no
oh see oh yeah
oh no
i don't
when you throw a flash near a dead body
the dead body moves i forgot
is this available in modern warfare
online too i don't think so i think
they're finally just dropping all
support for that
it's in warzone there there is stuff
there is uh uh
events going on for the the haunting in
war zone and we'll get to that for sure
you might see me i can't move i
shouldn't be moving
man i should also
i'm torn i hate sitting here oh but i'm
safe
it's either run out the clock or take on
all of these ghostface
bad guys and i might just stay here and
see if this works this is a pro strat
just kidding but
it's actually the worst strat and
literally camping out here but if they
see me
it's over
is this the map from bo2 yeah they added
it standoff is in black ops
cold war
does he see me
he doesn't see me
that guy might see me
i'm trying not to
move all the screaming
it needs a night mode that would be so
cool i think there's a night mode in
warzone again there's a night time for
dansk and we'll get to it um this is
just the first thing i tried
i know either either love or hate cold
war but it got a lot of updates for the
spooky time
sorry i think i set the delay to really
long it might be a 30 second delay on
stream so if i'm
not responding quick enough
okay now here we go
can i survive or do i have to kill them
that is the question
now i'm just mason with a knife this is
great
i still have my stun too
oh yeah i got one
buzzkill i wonder if i lose if i don't
kill them all we're gonna we're gonna
find out because i have five seconds
yay
survivors escaped
well that was cool you can just hold out
if that's your play style you can just
hold out and um
not fight you can be a pacifist in this
game if you want to
oh no
it's even called the scream knife that's
funny round five how many rounds are
there
that was not helpful at all
escape the killer and secret night mode
is really good yeah it's it's such a
it's such a small change that really
just like
uh
turning the verdance mode into night
mode was a really small change that was
just awesome it didn't take much i don't
imagine but it was just so fun it was
really spooky it was
it was on theme it was really nice
and they're doing it it again this year
except you're not a zombie this time
when you die you're a ghost
so we'll get to that after some maybe
after this
okay they're around here somewhere
should i go back to my spot over there
what do you think
i want to unping there we go
oh
oh boy
well this mode is pretty nice i can look
at chat hey guys
nighttime just cuts down visibility and
makes tension higher see that's spooky
that's perfect
oh
[Music]
the footsteps are loud so i don't even
want to move around too much but
i also don't want to bore you guys to
that look i'm looking at a wall yay
oh [ __ ] that guy's dead
dead af
can i go up here
come on cold war black ops cold war was
let you jump on anything i swear now of
course they're not letting me
oh no
eat this
that was embarrassing oh okay that's
pretty cool
i'll take that l because he he's very
flashy
born killer right here
me too i love the screens
uh
screams
oh snap
just get out of here just get out of
here
oh well you got one
oh
rambo
we lost rambo
see that was okay can we stop showing
this
it was the best play though fine
very flashy
cool i leveled up
all right let me let me back out
check the store
see what's up and then we'll pick
another game mode um
in the chat let me know what you guys
want to see
uh want me to check out the other modes
in cold war or do you want me to switch
over to warzone they both have spooky
content
also in in warzone i got the stg 44
unlocked i don't know how i didn't i
didn't earn it in the battle pass yet i
think it just glitched into my inventory
so if you want to see that too let me
know
i can also try to do the missions
to unlock the new smg
brandon hernandez what's up man
always good to see you
oh so here's what's in the bundle
it's available for a month i won't be
picking this one up
but
check it out
that's funny
ghost face with not a knife
but the am uh what is it amp63
a gun
looking good man
here we go
like the blood splatter last year i
unlocked the oh shoot
leave the lobby yeah i don't want to i
don't want to do that one again
for a bit let's see here
here we go
warzone stuff modern warfare okay cool
cool cool cool i will let's do that yeah
let's see what modern warfare i'm sorry
what warzone is offering oh that's funny
i don't like charms and i wouldn't even
i wouldn't even use this if i had it but
that's
that's on theme for scream that's
perfect
that's cool
last year i got the um
leather face
skin
what's this execution look like
oh my god
is that in the movie i don't remember oh
a tech nine a bloody tec-9
who's that in the chat dracula says he's
cool but he sticks out like a sore thumb
i don't know man the all-black it might
work uh was there another one here's the
new gun by the way before i jump into
warzone
um
that's a cool skin
you know
i don't know what it is the older i get
the more i just like regular
you know uh guns with no skin no not
because it's you know these stand out
sometimes if you're if you're serious
about playing and that's funny because
i'm not really that serious about
playing but i just i like the aesthetic
of uh more realistic i guess this is
cool though and i have plenty of
blueprints but moving on
oh my oh wow
that was a lot
that was a lot
let's see here okay
i'll back out here and switch over to
warzone and see what's up there
actually before i do just while i'm here
i'm going to double check
yeah i'm going to see
what modes are because i want to come
back to this and try some infected
uh some scream death match
what's the one i just did what was it
called
was it the scream death match uh maybe i
goofed up but
uh we'll come back to that in a little
bit i don't think this whole stream will
be
warzone related
okay war zone it is let's go
i'm thirsty
okey dokey
how are we doing chat
noon to noon
i hope this doesn't take forever
i swear if i just let this run it'll do
this all day
sometimes i gotta back out and just try
again
warzone let me okay i'm seeing from the
gamespot trailers chat that they want to
see some infected for sure i'll check
that out after this
spooky just abruptly cut it off
there we go so it is let's check it out
the ghosts of verdansk all right
excuse me i got a hiccup
let's just jump right in
oh
that's good that's nice um
last year there were some funny moments
from um
oh yes i'm on ps5
there were some funny moments from
streamers getting scared shitless with
all this spooky stuff
um i laughed out loud when i watched
that jordy video where he just kept
getting
he kept getting freaked out by those uh
care packages that scream at you the
fake ones
that was great
oh i played outbreak
while i was testing the stream and all
zombies modes right now have the zombies
with pumpkin heads just like last year
so that's really fun
ghost is
i mean that's that's a pretty scary
set up but let me see if if i have uh i
know i have
more operators that will um
don't i have one from uh you know last
year
oh i don't there's so many now i don't
even know where to look
i'll just stick with a ghost
cool
guy look at that guy dressed as adler
oh yeah you like my the scar load out
man
the scar
i really i still really love guns from
modern warfare
in warzone they get outclassed by every
gun in cold war basically but
i love them
and um i use the scar sometimes it's
it's my first default loadout that's why
you saw ghosts with it hide here while
you can
soon the fun begins
i don't know how to use keyboard and
mouse um i'm not really good at it now
short answer no
it's funny i grew up playing pc games
but like really young like uh you know
doom but when when fps games got really
advanced i was i was on console already
turn this down a little bit
that's nice they're giving the scare
warning again
see this car is all right
it just has not enough bullets and the
fire rate's slow but it's a tank i also
like the recoil not bad
it's not bad at all
no get away from me
i'll play as john mclean okay i will
next i will next match i did had a i did
have to pick up that bundle when it came
out
all right guys wish me luck
that's funny
ghost and ghost face
yeah theo this car holds a special place
my no i'm not the leader good
stay where you are and you'll be gassed
run and you'll be hunted
okay it's so dark uh let's try
why don't we why don't we try this
are you all in are you out
this dude just jumped okay
fine
a lot of people are probably gonna go
for that okay that's a good idea we'll
go there
road to that
you need to know my gun loadout i'll
show you guys but i mean it's not the
it's not the priority here but i will
show you my lousy loadouts after this
match
i took all my stuff
come on you're all supposed to be on a
team and share wait
give me that money give me that bag
the iron hide come on man i suck with
this gun
well no one went for this thing so i'm
gonna go for it
um i wish i could
watch the skies i heard him i heard his
i heard his
stupid parachute
i swear yeah you guys don't need to see
my i mean i'll show it to you
i'm not
you whoa
that is a bad guy come back here
it's too dark you went upstairs go go go
go
oh my god
i meant to do that i want you guys to
see what it looks like um
to be a ghost
okay get up get up everyone around you
dies
coincidence
super jump
oh wow i think that was nerf from last
year but whatever it's still here
get away from me
i need oh there's a real human over here
i jumped way too high
and teleport wow okay oh that didn't
really do much
and i jumped on the roof that has no why
is the phone ringing
what's the dog doing
oh
that's not a door wow i think they
killed that guy
okay i have to have to figure out where
that phone is it's definitely a scream
reference
do you like scary movies hello
where's the phone oh well i'm gonna go
find people
someone in the chat dracula says screw
her dance are you a rebirth let's see
what happens
what's this
this can't go in
but your enemies have to come out
oh
see footsteps here there he is
he was here okay yeah he's hiding out
here i would too
oh this guy's toast why did he leave the
circle oh well
i would have tried that too
someone over here
hey don't shoot
now he's trying to run for his life
check this out
zoinks
wow
why am i jumping so ridiculously high
over here
hey
he's over here guys
oh
wait if you get three of those orbs i
think you turned back into a human just
like last year really is like a reskin
of last year but that's fine because i
loved it last year
where the humans at
teleport let's see how well does it work
okay it's just a quick
jump forward it's not that far
do they have this on rebirth island
that's a great question that'd be
perfect uh rebirth island is based off
of alcatraz as you may know and that's a
scary place
so i'll look for you next time
we are far
wait these little spirit things i should
be picking up shouldn't i why are they
oh no they're fellow ghosts okay
remember last year it was vials if you
get like you know a number of vials then
you can um turn back into a human
oh
the train
spooky train
refill ammo
an airstrike during this mess
it's actually pretty smart
come on
okay i'm getting closer to humans
is there double xp there that'd be a
great idea i don't know for sure though
[Laughter]
this dude's camping out up here
it's over for you pal
wait what the hell
he's good he's on the oh
i went the wrong way
i used my um what's it called the
teleport and i got behind him that was
really cool
what the hell
that guy's good he got me
he's that guy's good and i'm bad
okay well that was fun um we can try
that again i wanted to back out and see
what's up for
everything else going on um
but yeah that was bad it was just like
last year
it's fun when you have a team uh of
friends for sure
rebirth resurgence uh i think it's the
same old i don't think it's night time
hmm
what do i have to do to unlock this gun
let's see here
okay play five matches on the playlist
okay
or in war zone complete five matches of
multiplayer
there's a lot i don't think i'll be
grinding for this on stream but there it
is on the right side there
okay what did i unlock
oh yeah this has been broken for a while
i hate that little green square so i try
to clear it out and it won't go away
i don't have any new
whatever
um what am i doing here okay let me back
out actually i see did i unlock anything
no
sorry okay
so it looks like in war zone the big the
big thing might just be
the ghost of her dance and i'm down to
keep playing that if you guys want
or i can check back with cold war and um
tr they had more game game modes like um
spooky prop hunt or i can play zombies i
mean if you guys have a preference let
me know but i think i might
yeah let me know what you guys want to
see but for now just so i'm not wasting
time i'll play i'll play another match
of uh
ghosts of verdansk
go back to my gun oh yeah this is not a
sick loadout i swear i'm telling you
it's it's like
just it's a it's a loadout that i like
but i wouldn't say it gets me
far that much i'm also you know
you know i'm not mlg over here but
that's that's my loadout
wow i have a
frangible on there i forgot
i have a perk
no one uses perks in war zones see this
is why i don't win very much
i think i need three of those spirits to
return to human form
and i got two of them in the last match
oh crap i forgot to switch to john
mcclane
someone in the chat wanted to see that
a bruin lmg um i have that i love that
gun
but um
i don't think i have a class for it
right now i have a
i have a class for the
rally
kilo
the row see raw rao
rpk all these loser classes oh here we
go here's the um
this is the stg um somehow it got
glitched into my
uh my class setup i didn't even unlock
it yet but here
there is a donnie darko bundle confirmed
check it out
get some peace and quiet over here and
show you guys the stg it rips dude has
10 attachments
it's it's broken
and i can't inspect it because uh it's
glitching out
oh but here it is
jumpy is all hell but up close game over
i should have tested it on a human but
yeah uh taco in the gamespot trailers
chad says that gun has zero recoil when
you fire it
yeah actually i'm not sure if you're
talking about the
the stg or my uh
scar class
this car is pretty good recoil because
fire rate's so low
who's miss oh i thought it was a dude i
was like who's mr ponytail over here
it's uh
what's her name i forgot her name from
the campaign
enemies and gas closing in run run run
jump there
let's do it
wait is this the same place we landed
last night no oh bad guy
let's scooch over here
with mr nasty
oh wait
yes
oh no
good lord that was fast well yeah park
thank you that's her name
that sucks because i loved her character
in the cold war and i forgot her name
entirely
get me up get me up
i'm gonna get that guy who killed me
[Laughter]
i punched him to death but his friend
got me
what
oh wow wait this is i'm a ghost why do i
have to request redeployment i thought i
just came back maybe because i died too
many times cause i'm scrub
oh
this guy knows what's up
oh we can watch this much better
gameplay from this guy
oh no
oh no there you go there you go
i was outnumbered
oh my god
yeah i didn't see that going well oh we
lost very hard okay
let me you know what guys i gotta try
prop hunt i need to try at least one
match of prop hunt i'm gonna go back to
cold war
and then i'll come back to this but you
know in the meantime in the chat please
let me know what else you'd like to see
um
forget who asked for it in chat but i
will switch to i will also switch to uh
john mclean for you
bruce willis my mom's uh my mom loves
bruce willis i always think of her
it's good to see mason again i'm really
glad they
added him in i knew they would they had
they even added hudson so i was like
they're gonna add mason for sure
aaron webster yeah hopefully you know
they're adding their ricochet um
anti-cheat system
soon uh god i've heard i don't know if
it's true but i've heard it's already
been
tampered with it's really sad i hope not
or i hope that
you know one rumor is that um
activision put out that
you know
there they leak their own code for
people to break it and then they can
work on it from there i don't know that
that'd be cool because i hope they could
fix it but
i don't know ooh infected that's the
mike myers mode where is prop hunt
you better i swear
nuketown halloween what's so what's so
halloween about that
versus bots fire team party games maybe
it's here
yeah come on i want to play prop pine
it's spooky
the ghost aspect is really dumb yeah you
think so
i like it um i'm no i'm clearly
not that good but i i like the idea it
just for dansk and and warzone is you
know it's a very one note thing you know
you try to go in and get the wins
um
using your guns or whatever but
switching it up with ghosts i think they
at least tried something and it's it's
fun that way it's it's for dancing a
whole new light i think
or at least a different light
if people aren't playing prop hunt i'll
be really sad i was really happy when
they announced it the other day
74
74
90.
this isn't a very spooky map but um
let's see let's have a little fun
when prop hut came to
uh call of duty 4 remastered
it was the funnest i've had with the
game
for so long
it was the funniest thing
okay what should i um
should i
hmm
no
look through rotate
change oh no bad sign
i'll be this little garbage can
one second left
come on i have to be a realistic garbage
can in a realistic place this looks okay
okay
no wait hold on over here
oh [ __ ]
oh that's perfect i'm not moving
lt rotate
oh mike myers scream death match
don't do
it no why am i frozen oh i hit down the
thumbstick and locked myself in
hey why didn't this guy get concussed
wait what's so spooky about this i
thought there was supposed to be like i
could turn into a pumpkin or something
come on
this guy
is a garbage can amongst garbage cans
if i can't turn into a pumpkin or
something i'll back out of
prop hunt unless you guys like this mode
i love this mode but um i understand
it's not what the kids want to see all
the time
wait watch out oh
mike myers is scream death match okay
oh no
that's the one i played already that's
uh yeah i did that at the beginning of
the stream
it's like the knife mode
knife only
oh this guy is juking them
okay now we gotta look for them they
give us a ksp why why would you do that
it's the first smg i got gold i think
but
i'm no good with three round bursts this
guy's going ham
what else do i have oh check yeah
classic
welcome back
rogue props i love how they got hudson's
voice actor to say these silly things
and i honestly don't even know wait all
right
two garbage cans suspicious
oh they're getting concussed
af over there i gotta see what's up
there's action
phony baloney cones
wait someone got concussed again
got one woohoo
i stole that one my bad
hmm
oh my god i gotta follow the concussion
grenades
who are you fighting
there's a new sm
hmm
yeah this isn't very haunting at all i
won't play this anymore um
because it's not spooky
or all the pumpkins hey
my uh my shitty game skills are the
spookiest thing like i made a decoy i'm
such an idiot
where'd he go
this morning before i started so oh he's
up there
now he made a decoy again
maybe he's behind that decoy look at
that god how do you get up there
i feel like such a dumb ass
that's how you play the game everyone's
got to feel like a dumb ass before they
get chased by a lawn mower or a chip oh
you get points for that i forgot
okay
not spooky moving on
yeah we're all the scary
good question i'm getting out of this
game mode they really
advertise that this would be spooky but
i'm going to check that
uh yeah the nuketown oh thank you so
much i'm playing regular prop hunt like
a doofus and the prop hunt i want is in
the playlist
the nuketown halloween great thank you
guys
so we'll get to that too see what's up
look at this i have no weapon
there are just ghost face killers
with armed with knives oh yeah john
mcclane just for you
uh whoever that was that's funny yeah
mute everybody here all right here we go
um nuketown halloween team deathmatch
are kill confirmed
well these are just
regular modes
tdm i guess
all right let's see how nuketown got the
old halloween facelift you guys know
that uh the voice of ghost face killer
in the first movie was steve bloom
oh my god
yep yep people are still playing cold
war um
it's strange you know like everyone
there's a fear my friends and i all
loved
modern warfare and war zone and then
cold war came out and a lot of people
were like it feels backwards like like
but but the people who like cold war
from what i've noticed just they love
cold war and it's it doesn't matter it's
classic call of duty it's super fast
the guns it's goofy you know what should
i pick
i didn't scream all these are ass tech
nine no i mean i'm ass using all of
these
after watching mlg
you know whatever the call of duty
championships i tried making classes
with their guns that they use
i see why they did it those are some
steady ass guns
man you guys are just gonna see some uh
some classic richie uh goofing up
gameplay
watch i'm about to die right here
that's what i mean john mclean down
but yeah this is pretty cool
that's cute i like when they do this for
halloween
and christmas especially that's always
fun hey
looking around here like a doofus
um and it's not working out
okay
my tec-9 was smoking i didn't fire a
bullet yet that's pretty funny
oh god that scared me
wait he was downstairs
watch out park
hey there he is
i ran it
god this is why i was happy to play prop
hunt because uh um
i tried tweaking my settings for um
uh controller because there are so many
so many settings you can mess with now
and i think i screwed it up
see how my aim was delayed i could turn
up the sensitivity but then i go crazy
and i i i can't i don't know i haven't
figured it out for a while
my settings in warzone are okay but for
for a cold war i never perfected them
plus i'm just not
look at it
hey
someone's named elon musk on this map
i got one guy
and someone threw a c4 at me and i'm
dead okay
did you guys like um scream deathmatch
we can go back to playing that um
let me know let me know in the chat you
guys
look at that see
shuffle around too much me um
let's just mix it up look at all these
goofy ass glasses
the dog's barking
the guy's here to uh
yeah my dog is barking this is
distracting
i think the guy is here to replace
her dryer
i can't think
is donnie coming out yeah you guys want
to keep it let me
sorry i was looking at the chat for a
sec and uh oh that's harder to see at
night
oh that dread skin is pretty cool but it
stands out way too much
this guy keeps coming for me man this
guy this guy loves me
that's okay
oh no
see
what okay let me try something
here um yeah maybe it's a little too
high or when i adm at low zoom i think
this is the problem
i don't know there's a million things
that can go wrong with these settings
also uh oh crap
oh [ __ ] wrong guy
no ah see
whatever whatever scream deathmatch okay
let's just do that that was fun we had
fun with that
and uh it's much better than my game
play here so let's
yeah that was really bad
i heard someone
come on one bullet away
oh they threw
oh
i was just lucky
no touch red no
oh hi
oh man what's up man it's good to see
you
oh no i was
i can't do two things at once i swear i
swear
out of here
here we go ah
well
you guys are discussing vanguard i'm i'm
ready for vanguard i mean
during the beta i was uh i was happily
reminded of
of modern warfare so i was like you know
what i'll give this a shot
we've taken the lead i thought it was
strange and bold
uh to make another world war two game
because
people see world war two games and
they're like no right away so i thought
it was very brave but
it's not you know it's far from
historically accurate so they're gonna
have fun i've had fun with gameplay
an attack helicopter
it's all my fault
with spider
uh
uh
but yeah i mean you can't there's no you
can't please one call of duty fan with
every game every year you know
you like what you like and i like modern
warfare i thought cold war was okay
i think i'm gonna have the same feelings
about vanguard i think it's gonna be
okay
uh customizing oh my god customizing
with 10 attachments has got to be some
fun no matter what anyone says it's
gotta happen
we're gonna have some fun making some
doofy ass classes
and uh jonathan ferguson our firearms
expert reacts is on board to
talk about everything that's wrong with
with vanguard so you can at least look
forward to that i know you guys love
that guy he's the he's the best
there's so much fire oh there was an a
palm strike okay
oh they're spawning over here watch i
bet you
nope
i like the music
i'm dragging my team down but somehow
they're still winning they are carrying
me
random grenade
c4
i'm toast what the
oh
god
i'm torn i hate sitting here
kind of just want to hang back and enjoy
nuketown look around like
take on all of these ghost face
and i might just stay here and see if
this works
hello
sorry um if you're here for like you
know
you guys know me if you're here for high
level gameplay and you're in the wrong
stream
just try to
see what's up see what's new
and i'll go back to uh scream deathmatch
i think i think we had fun with that
boomer the dingo says i personally don't
see the issue with world war ii games
yeah i think the only issue
that a lot of people feel is that they
were they were done for 10 years like in
a row
uh and you know
they moved on to modern shooters that
was a big success and then they're going
back to world war ii like some people
just have mixed feelings about that
might wait for the reviews of vanguard
that's fair yeah informed decision i
like it smart with your money smart with
your independent of the mass
media and their thoughts
fortunately it's my job to cover this
stuff so i will be
quick enough getting vanguard okay
oh yeah i'm out of here i don't want to
play
uh we
i wanted to get wrecked again uh back to
scream death and that sounds fun
infected i haven't tried that yet um
you know what i'll do that i'll do
infected
and then i'll go back to scream death
match just because we haven't tried this
yet oh yeah i got one
i should try the jason hudson operator
oh man i didn't i didn't
uh i don't have that unless he came with
the the battle pass i don't have hudson
yeah
he's over
here love hudson but uh yeah i didn't
want to pony up but i did pony up for
these guys i had to have them
and weaver god i'm such a sucker but i
love zombies now if you guys ever want
to see zombies mode anything let me know
not fight especially for vanguard i'm
excited that treyarch is developing that
oh no
infected okay good we're going infected
let's see how this goes it's even called
the scream knife
um oh they have pre-made classes wow
this looks like
oh my god what's going on
here this is what i'm talking about this
is spooky everything's green
i have a knife and i'm i'm growling look
at my hand
oh
you know what else is also hard i'm
still thinking just about cold war
modern warfare and how people like you
know both of them are strongly like one
over the other it's also hard to enjoy
both
because um
there's no space on the hard drive i
feel like anymore like what the hell
it's a classic problem that just hasn't
gone away okay they're around here
somewhere
who are we looking for oh god that guy's
name i'm not gonna read that
all right someone's hiding
and we won okay great
love from india what's up
rohan hi welcome
oh
oh man this map
they're gonna all camp out up there
that guy's that guy's aim was a little
hmm a little sus
oh no
oh my god his head blew off that was
pretty cool
yeah
they're gonna be strong places to camp
in these maps i know it
yeah collab infinity says i can't wait
for jonathan ferguson to have an
aneurism reacting to the cursed weapons
of vanguard for sure
he that's gonna be like an hour long
episode i bet
the guys uh the team over in the uk
is actually right now as we speak
they just finished they went to the
royal armories after
it had been you know
closed for the last year and a half they
finally went
and they recorded a bunch of stuff with
jonathan um so look forward to that oh
no
matthias mathias
hi welcome
oh okay that was pretty cool
oh yeah um aaron webster in the chat
just says zombies you guys want me to
play just some zombies i know they have
modes there too
i kind of wanted to do a little bit of
everything so that's not a bad idea all
the zombies right now have pumpkin heads
it's pretty funny
oh snap
what the get out of here just get out of
here
oh for some reason my stomach hurts
we lost rambo
see that was okay can we stop showing
this yeah the space okay you're on pc
boomer and you say all the stuff is
your pc is sweating because of those two
games it's no fair man i mean
i don't know
it's a very complicated issue
hard drives you sure you can always get
a bigger hard drive but like you
shouldn't have to i don't know
hey another john mcclane what up man
this is for you
that guy's hiding he's like f you guys i
don't trust anyone
i'm not infected wait
i can also try to do the missions
to unlock the new
is the bull frog still so meta right now
everyone was using the bullfrog in
warzone like they just discovered it and
i was like i
like the bullfrog is it really that good
you let me know chat available for a
month
that guy's name is players okay where
are they infected
is it about to happen
no there's one infected he's probably
hiding
a gun right okay he has to hide because
if we kill him it's over right
oh someone's firing like the blood
last year
oh one person got infected that's all it
takes
oh no
wow
he had higher
uh what's it called
uh
higher health bar
no he didn't i died in like two seconds
i just really stink it this game dude
favorite cod that's that's tough
i have the most nostalgia for you know
of course modern warfare and modern
warfare 2
of course of course um
i think mono for 2019 was really cool
too i loved it oh man i was trying to
tomahawk that guy
well the infection is spreading there
are only six left
saying that in 2022 is a
a little too on the nose it's sad
oh man
okay let's let's be tactful about this
i like how you wear like a suit when
you're a zombie though
[Applause]
yeah we gotta work in groups like this
i'll follow these guys
i was swinging there we go
there we
go be nice if they had a zombie operator
that would be nice that'd be funny
all right there's seven left
no
yeah seven alive
let's corner them
three left
they're cornering oh that guy got the
panda skin that's funny
i was like oh the zombies have a higher
health bar no man i just suck
i'm going around going around being
tactful
spetsnaz ever dealt with zombies
have i tried the scream death match yeah
vintage gaming what's up welcome to the
chat welcome to the stream um that's the
first thing i did and after
after this mode i'm gonna go back and
try it again it was fun
oh my god that guy was on a on a tear
i shouldn't have earned any xp that was
a bad match for me
i swear if i just let this run it'll do
this all day
sometimes yeah let me back out for it
for anyone's just joining there's a lot
of spooky stuff going on we're just
playing all the modes and seeing what's
up
if you play the modes and do the
challenges you can get the new lappa
the lap
smg right there on the bottom right very
cool
uh but there are new modes like um
our you know limited time modes
newtown is decked out for halloween
there are two new operator bundles i'll
show you here just for anyone tuning in
i'll do this real quick
uh thank you for joining by the way see
say hello in the chat
ghost face killer himself
and i don't know where he is i don't
think they've included him yet but there
is supposed to be the donnie darko
bunny guy ben ben the bunny but he's not
here um and i don't know when he'll show
up
that's nice
yeah no he's not here
so let's go to scream deathmatch it's
pretty fun
there it is has its own
tab i love it
blink official over on the gamespot
trailers channel says hi
hi care
packages me too vintage gaming the the
the voice lines that they recorded for
ghost face they're pretty great
while i was testing the stream and all
zombies modes right now
oh the disciple type operator that'd be
fun the the disciple from zombies mode
those are cool
they're a little cliche looking but like
i like what they do i like how they take
over the minds of
down zombies and like give them more
power
screen deathmatch
oh they dropped me in the middle of the
of a match
god look at that already dressed as
adler
oh
no
oh my god
oh
that's scream death match in a nutshell
i got dropped right into this match
oh damn see this is how i want to play i
want to be i want to be this good
damn this guy's good
[Music]
i did good last time we played on
standoff and i just kind of hid and uh
i survived one round and then got killed
another round
there's a ghost face over there
oh no he's just using the operator skin
hiccup excuse me
leave me alone
oh no
he's over there oh no
even john mcclane can't
uh duke it out with ghost face killer
oh this guy again
undermine different guy different guy
and last time i survived for so long now
i'm going to sit here and watch as
punishment
damn
all right guys
hey don't hang out up here we saw what
happened last time don't be don't be
that guy you're not that guy
yeah theo this car holds a special place
[Laughter]
all the screaming
that part is like prop hunt
after a few seconds you scream
you can't be too silent in this game
okay it's so dark uh let's try
i don't know how this ends why don't you
come out are y'all
steve bloom the original voice of um
the ghost face from scream
he's done so many call of duty games i
don't know why he
didn't come back to do this
he was in like call of duty one he's
like one of the first voices you hear
that guy is the best
and he's dempsey in zombies mode why
didn't he do the voice for this i don't
know i don't know
boy i died way too early i'm sorry guys
there we go here we go
hey one-on-one fight over here
well no one went for this thing so i'm
gonna go for it
so this guy's a survivor right here king
pina he's still alive he's got five more
seconds oh it's 1v1 look at the top left
over there
whoa
that is a bad guy come back here
it's too dark
you went upstairs go go go go
mtc is running dry
this guy is just screaming
come on i thought there was five seconds
left oh now it's fifteen
here's the other perspective there he is
1v1 let's go
why is the ghost
oh that's a survivor
run you have four seconds
nope he lost dude it's
over oh wow
that's funny
10th place that's ridiculous dude
no not mason
anyway let me try to survive for much
longer this time
oh
and i jumped on the roof
this music that's nice
that's the creepy violins
oh i did five matches okay well
we're slowly earning the uh the the
little smg
where's the phone i gotta be someone
spookier
someone in the chat dracula says groover
dance are you a rebirth that's not
spooky
let's see here
do i have any spooky
adler skins nope just badass ones
[Music]
i have a pretty uh like a i think a dia
de los muertos
or at least like a cool skull cowgirl
one there we go it's not spooky kind of
spooky
let's see
i didn't pick it
all right guys um
i'll do one more of these
and then um
see here
i mean this could last for a while but
um i started a little late today so i'll
go on for a little bit here
over here maybe a few more matches
ooh on express this will be fun this is
a nice
medium-sized
map we doing out there vintage gaming is
also playing
nice three of those i think you turned
back into a human just like last year
it really is like a reskin
where is everyone
i guess we're all split up because
oh no
no no why
okay i'm gonna run away
got some friendlies over here
oh no
damn i was gonna try to punch him from
the back but
he knows i'm here now i'm gonna run for
my life
where can i hide there's a lot of places
to hide but
someone someone pinged danger
oh i'm out of here
i know i stunned him but i'm too scared
i'd rather just
hide
i want to survive
last time i died immediately and there
was no oh shoot
the train okay
my tomahawk
i can't pick it up
oh i'm freaking out man
yes now i can fight them or hide
okay i'm getting closer to humans
is there double xp
[ __ ]
i know i can fight back but i'd rather
hide i'd rather hide
get away from me
man of course it was all on my shoulders
i'm just kidding
dang i thought i had we were going back
and forth i thought i had him
collab infinity said something i do not
want to see oh wait something i do
want to see is the new advanced warfare
all right
i liked advanced warfare i didn't when
it launched because i wasn't into you
know
power sliding boost jumping all that
stuff i was not into it i didn't play
black ops 3 or anything for a while i
went back and i played all of them
all of them and i liked advanced warfare
i did
and i like i like how
oh no
i was turned into a killer
well i'm a better killer than survivor i
guess two in a row
i think it's the same old i don't think
it's nighttime
there's always another victim
damn
there you go oh this mask
sorry i thought there was someone behind
me now i'm losing mason
oh it's woods never
mind i don't think i'll be grinding
but there it is on the right side
we're just having a all out this fight
here where'd woods go
oh it's another woods
that was dope i'm doing pretty good i
just ruined it watch i jinxed it
i've seen this one before
the update is out yes
else banko
he went on top of the train okay i'll go
there too
this is full speed by the way
his bloody footprints on the ground
that's funny
this is top speed i can't run faster
than this
come on he's the last guy
someone else was here
nope friendly friendly
two survivors
oh they might have turned into kill or
they might have been armed with knives
now
can i inspect
cool
now it's like 2v2 and we have 45 seconds
to kill them and they have knives
and the uav turned on all right all
right
he's up there
i know where he is
the bloody footprints
yeah we did it all right
are there jump scares in this one um i
think in you know when you play
the war zone
uh um
oh what did they call it in war zone hey
my replay yeah
it's like
god what is the word with the war zone
version called like um
anyway the battle royale version there
are crates and they i think they might
scream they they give you a warning on
the
screen that says hey there's flashing
and screaming and jump scare so
probably not in cold war at least i
don't think so
we tried out um
zone a little earlier i just kind of
wanted to do as much as i can
but the update is out now
that guy's hiding
okay good he's not a killer
oh shoot
crap
up close that's a delayed ass flashbang
there's another oh
it's hard when you have
you see that goat that guy has the
operator skin and he's being chased by
an actual goat there's too many
too many scream masks
survivor oh crap
no
well i did good last time and i'm paying
the price
all right let's let's let's spectate oh
man we're going down like flies
this car is pretty good hey you guys
remember that
uh this guy's a calling card
it's from black ops one or two no one
the spooky chess and war zone were too
much for me yeah they're loud they they
they they're super loud
they're funny though when you see
streamers and stuff reacting to them and
getting freaked out it's hilarious
he says ill god oh man why come on you
clicked on the video for a reason man
you like cod
that's okay
doomslayer
let's scooch hello here all right 3v2
that's it
that always works in the movies
oh no
good lord that was good
yeah
this is so fun i love halloween
what's everyone doing in the chat for
halloween i don't think nice doing
anything maybe hand out some candy
oh we're going to we might go to
something i don't know
i don't even have a costume
i should just go as a loser streamer boy
oh [ __ ] oh friendly friendly
come on i'll switch it up who's left
in a few seconds in 15 seconds this
survivor right here will get a knife to
fight back with
you just got to stay alive
oh no there you go
yes he is now armed with now he looks
just like one of them because he has the
scream operator bundle on too
he won right yeah
for halloween emilio says i'm gonna be
eating dumplings all right
no cap
at din tai fung all right i love
dumplings
although
i stopped ah embarrassing kill cam of me
getting
sliced
i'll be right back
paulie push kick what's up hey welcome
all right
let me know now guys in the chat the
last is that
let me know what mode you want to see
uh we can go back to warzone we can
uh go back to nuketown we can play this
again because the next match i think
will be my last i gotta wrap it up
so let me know now while i'm still in
this game
this mode is pretty fun
webster yeah hopefully you know they're
adding their ricochet um
anti-cheat system soon
all the screams
[Laughter]
you scream because it's like prop hunt
it gives it gives the killers a a
helpful hint as to where you are it's
great
but i love how they
the voice actors are just like
we're all the killers okay there's
two killers now two killers six
survivors
i heard the phone
i heard it last time too i want to see
if it's an easter egg
but of course it stopped ringing
oh only five survivors now
i should have helped my guy out but i'm
too scared i think so
i like it i'm not clearly
get away from me
oh man he got me
oh there were two of them there
that flashbang didn't do [ __ ]
oh well
little death wants to see the war zone
halloween spectacular for sure i can do
that again
um when you die in war zone you turn
into a ghost it's just like last year
except you're not a zombie or a ghost
oh my god so chill that's funny
i'm such an old-school call of duty
player uh and stubborn in my ways that i
that was really funny to see like i
don't i'm not a fan of tactical jump
jump shots and
weapon swapping i'm
really just a
curmudgeon i'm just like
geezer call of duty player that uh
people
the favorite comments i get when uh i'm
streaming and you know people see my
horrendous gameplay is uh you play like
a bot and i'm like yeah cause i don't
i'm not
the kids are so fast and so good today
and they're on mouse and keyboard
but i still like it i mean obviously
i've played i've played call of duty
since cod 4
and then a few months ago i played every
call of duty and made a video about it
that you can watch one second right here
on game spot
yeah
this guy stayed alive just long enough
oh that's perfect
round five goodness gracious oh well
okay
there's no one here i'll throw it in the
garbage
it's showtime
watch i'm gonna be a killer i know it
nope
let's stick together woods
no
oh crap
he executed me immediately
oh wow that was embarrassing
well i'm gonna quit i'm not gonna rage
quit but i just want to quit because i
want to get to war zone i'm dead and
unless you guys like this mode
i'm 28 i am a bot says amelia
yeah i think i entered bot hood in my
30s
the kids are just faster
than me
okay let's try out the one i played
already the war zone um the mode
dom i'm not sure if there's double xp
this would be a great time for you know
treyarch to implement that but i'm not
sure
i'll check
i think some modes do have double xp but
i can't confirm i will in a moment here
so chill says i'm 38 i'm most definitely
a bot
well i mean thanks for from one bot to
another i really appreciate you guys
being here and
just having some fun i just wanted to
see what this um
uh the halloween mode the haunting was
all about
but yeah you know we we do these streams
knowing damn well that there are
[Music]
some very talented people out there i'm
just uh just having fun being an old
geezer bot
we got a lot of bots in the chat i love
it i'm a bot i'm 34. i felt that
cass coupe uh john mclean you guys love
that john mcclane operator bundle i'll
put him on yeah i got him
let's see here do i have him selected
already no i have ghost
there he is
all right john mclean it is
[Laughter]
there we go ghosts of verdansk let's do
it and uh it looks like nothing here is
double xp
am i going to get donny darko i want to
um but he's not in the store right now
right now
well a few things um
yeah i don't i don't have any i don't
have enough cod points as you can see on
the top right there and um
the the ben bunny is not in the store
emilio says we're proud to be bots we
love john mclean and his bare feet hell
yeah man
i'm uh definitely a
uh i love all those movies i love die
hard it's the best christmas movie
yeah this isn't very haunting at all i
won't play this anymore
wacko no no no no i have not i don't
know what that is
yeah
so these are some awesome skins look at
this here i am just being john mcclane
i'm surrounded by spooky people
oh he's up there
okay manage the fear again
continue on in the afterlife
and survive
no or survive if you can last time i
died pretty quick but it's fun being a
ghost they make it
they make
get ready someone always dies
i'm just gonna drive away
as john mcclane
look who's on my team new master 69
that's from
avengers right
so chilled i saw that i saw that mini
doc i love that show uh movies that made
us they also have like the toy version
i love that and yeah i watched the die
hard one so good
um i went to
i went to like
film school that's how i learned how to
be an editor
and uh
i love seeing like behind the scenes
stuff for movies especially movies that
i love
blackout
uh jason acosta acosta yes
uh they are the screen bundle is in the
store
it's 20 bucks though
oh man i'm the squad leader all right
let's go let's let's let's do
all right so
i'm gonna go to the party enemies and
guests
just get some peace
you know quiet drop what do we think
team no one's agreeing with me no one
wants to go over there
all right
looks like uh
we got one we got one taker
fellow film graduate yeah
yeah yeah i'm a
film guy oh
someone's right behind me
oh
i hate i hate getting shot in the air so
i try to do everything to avoid it
i guess i get unnecessarily angry when i
get shot in the air
where's my friends
oh okay one guy's making it
well
i don't know if he'll make it he's going
to the old
wakatomi
all right we'll go here we'll go here
what do you think
all right he's ignoring
that
oh he can make it okay good good good
good
yeah then nakatomi plaza which is
perfect for john mclean but this guy can
make it so we're we're going
see this is what i wanted a nice chill
drop i don't think anyone is near us
what is this thing
oh this is a safety circle zombies can't
come in here
oh i thought that'd be a scary
what the hell crazy
i thought that was going to be a scary
great
let's move up uh new master 69
no that's uh
why lange
oh no
get away
oh no
oh
here we go
i think my friend got him this is the
homie right here i'm sticking with you
oh no another ghost is coming up on us
yeah i was [ __ ] with that sniper rifle
i'm not doing that again why did i even
pick it up
would you say the drop was so chill
no oh actually yeah it was it wasn't one
of the spooky ones it was so chilled
all right we're entering the circle
maybe i should get
okay there's a crate over here i'm going
for it kill me
let's see what happens when we put a
bunch of killers in one shrinking space
i got an mp5 yes all my friends are back
wait one of our friends is a ghost
that's fine
an mp5 perfect for john mclean are you
kidding me this is the best
that's what he uses in the movie
another mp5
okay do i have enough money for anything
just some armor i guess
come on i want a spooky um
you know
what the hell is this thing set up
i think it's upstairs uh i want to
spooky
no spooky craziness here
hey should we get in a truck that would
we survive in a truck like this
yeah where are the scare packages this
is an excellent question oh body armor
wait i'm already maxed out what the hell
am i doing
my truck
oh what's going on
wait okay i'm gonna stick with my friend
he um
he knew what was up he was he was good
or do you even want to use the truck
yeah he's on he's on board literally
can i run over the ghosts
that was distracting
wait is my friend here
yeah he's on board too let's go
yo can we just survive this way it's a
great tactic
well i mean it's a tactic
you guys like my horn
we don't have enough we almost have
enough for uh
i want to get money so we can get it
loadouts
no money
around for a little bit okay
stick together
stay with us
it's nice that we're still alive
um
let's see here
i like claymores
last stream uh when i was streaming with
aaron sampson claymore saved my life and
it got me a dub in war zone it was great
money
money money money
oh look a free loadout
let's go
oh no do you hear that that's so loud in
my earphones my headphones
more gas more running
heck yeah
like that'll do [ __ ] but whatever
oh but here's the stg guys it's broken a
f and they're gonna
has 10 attachments this is ridiculous
this gun and it's great at close
quarters
i hope i get to use it on somebody
because it's a trip
there are no scare packages this year
i'm really sad
okay let's let's um
i think we should get back on the truck
or at least head towards the circle
let's go
come on friends
this place tastes like death
well i'll be damned
movement okay okay but we got to move up
too oh you want to pick them off
oh my god this effect
let's see what happens when we put up on
two oh my
god space everything was so zoomed in oh
my god
okay you guys stay up on the top floor i
will
hang out down here
thanks for the advice
okay you still see him
there's a ghost in here
i should have stayed with my friends
they're over there i'm gonna go join
them
oh this guy's on the roof good move good
move takes a while well they can super
jump though zombies can super jump
oh my god all these sounds and stuff
got the ghost
oh goodness
ah
oh no
this effect
are we just gonna fight people right
here at the edge of the ring we should
move
those ghosts can survive the ring no
they got him
where
ah i'm just running around like an idiot
i can't see
i can't see
oh the ring
you know the gas
oh no
i have to move i have to move i split
away from my team that's no good
oh no
he barely whacked me look at my health
it's okay
oh no
oh my god
i have to wash my back
i don't think i need anything from the
store at the moment
oh no
oh they're so far from me i'm toast
i'm alone and i'm scared and everything
keeps happening on the screen
can i buy them back
i should have checked in the shop i'm an
idiot i should have checked the shop
more gas
you know what forget this i'm going for
a car i'm going to that shop right there
buy station
god do i have a lighter weapon yes i do
come on i can buy you guys back i hope
come on come on come on come on
oh he's alive wait
what i guess i can't buy them back even
though they're ghosts i want to return
them to the living
stairs
oh
they're getting beat up
let's see what happens when we put a
bunch of killers in one shrinking space
how long do you think you can last on
your own oh boy
sorry guys i haven't been very chatty
i'm uh i'm still alive
[Laughter]
dude what the hell is this
oh yeah i know oh god okay moving to the
ring moving to the ring
should have taken that car
can i jump this
yes i can
oh god let's talk man you're real all
right fine
they don't really hurt me that much when
they when they whack me
supreme
am i really talking like a ten-year-old
trying to stay young man
no i'm not really and i didn't even
notice
your pc is sweating
well i definitely don't play like a 10
year old i mean as in
10 year olds are much better at me than
this game
okay
where's the shop it's above me okay okay
that's not above me where the
it's outside
they're both gone they left
i'll buy a selfie i guess
this might not be a bad place to hide at
least temporarily
that was distracting
what even is gamespot
i mean i don't know man you clicked on
the video enemy soldier
you like call of duty then you're
welcome to hang out
love to have you
i gotta move a little bit
damn low ammo okay ar ammo
or i'll switch to the yellow mp5
oh boy
okay safely in
the circle
where'd that other ghost go man he's
probably right behind me
oh he jumped in front of me oh man
that won
what kind of odds am i getting good
question
okay
that was the scariest one of all so far
oh boy
safety don't make me laugh
um i don't know if i have the guts
someone's definitely here
see his footprints
launched an advanced uav were exposed
enemy uav overhead i tried the screen
death
oh let them fight each other now he's
gonna kill me damn
well
still get a shot as a ghost
maybe you can get my revenge
uh the ghost uh uh the ghostface voice
actor might have changed i mean there
are so many screen movies
i don't know what i was thinking theirs
now
well
16
better than last time remember i died
right away
all right you guys let me switch over to
bam i want to thank you guys for
watching and i hope you're able to play
this yourself the update is out now for
every platform
take care have a happy halloween and
i'll see you next time bye you guys
right yeah no he's not here
so let's go to scream deathmatch it's
pretty funny